[Music]
so I have to split the words out that
you just tried to place in my mouth I do
not know that I don't agree with the
premise and you have yet to prove it
here's the beauty though I don't have
you were to commit defamation even if no
it didn't and even assuming gu with your
audience and I'm only going to continue
speaking as though we're having a
dialogue even assuming that you don't
discuss the Caps that he would never pay
out the far lower settlement that they
have decided they would allow
considering this will go to a superior
court and we'll get Steven Steven
Steven you really think Pierce has taken
the time to read about this